start with
this if I could guess what Joe Biden's
New Year's resolution is I'd bet it's to
make it easier for illegals to cross our
border and then stay here and his move
late tonight tonight proves that we'd be
right the doj is now suing the state of
Texas for making illegal immigration a
State
Crime starting in March Texas law
enforcement officials would have been
able to arrest and jail illegals and the
judges could Deport them out of Texas to
their home country but that's
unconstitutional according to the Biden
regime Texas cannot run its own
immigration system they say and late
yesterday the doj asked the Supreme
Court to let border patrol cut through
and remove razor wire that the state of
Texas had put up to deter
illegals but kjp says that's not what it
actually does
government abits uh razor wire does not
prevent it does not prevent non-citizens
from unlawfully crossing that's not what
it does if anything it puts at risk it
puts the lives of the border patrol at
risk it puts them in
danger as an infantryman who's employed
quite a bit of razor wire in my life it
definitely prevents and is intended to
prevent and when you put it in wear
gloves that's helpful so then why did
border patrol agent Brandon Jud say this
to Laura last night there is not a
border patrol agent out there that wants
to cut this razor wire none of us want
to do
that of course makes sense joining us
now is Missouri Senator Eric Schmidt uh
Senator what is the bid Administration
doing
here well they're an open borders
Administration I mean you kind of have
to take them at their word now when they
came in on day one the first thing they
did was to reverse reverse all the
successful policies that they had under
President Trump right we had a secure
border we had remain in Mexico which
made Mexico the waiting room for all
these Asylum claims nine out of 10
Asylum claims are bogus but the Biden
Administration now just releases these
folks into the interior of United States
uh never to be seen again some people
are getting court dates seven eight
years down the road um title 42 which
was a very effective mechanism of
turning people away they got rid of that
too so this comes down to values right
we believe in America we believe in the
sovereign of our own border we believe
in American exceptionalism we believe in
the rule of law they don't believe in
those things the people running the
Biden white house right now are
unapologetically open borders it's what
they believe they don't think that uh
there you sort of they view themselves
as Global Citizens not really As
Americans and so this is now the
consequence this is 400,000 people came
across last month alone that's that's
the size of Pittsburgh St Louis Kansas
City each month if you add it all up 8
and a half million people since Joe
Biden's been president that's like the
17th largest state in the Union uh it's
total lawlessness it's a disaster and
they're not really interested in it
they're paying attention to it now
because of the polling but this is what
they want and this is what we've
got Senator Democrats are showing us
what they want in fact one of your
colleagues uh Senator Chuck Schumer is
making fun of the house trip of uh house
over 60 House Republicans that have been
to the Border today and says he's more
worried about something else listen to
Chuck Schumer to the house it's very
nice you go to the Border but the way to
get something done is work as we are in
the Senate on a bipartisan solution to
the Border crisis which will then unlock
money for Ukraine Israel uh the
indopacific and humanitarian aid for the
people in
Gaza so they're worried about Ukraine I
mean they could care less that Texas is
trying to secure its border Ukraine is
the Border they really care
about that's exactly right and and I'm
serving in the the United States Senate
uh all roads lead to Ukraine on all of
this stuff I mean Chuck Schumer is now
talking about an Omnibus Bill on a
continuing resolution that has to have
Ukraine money in it they're obsessed
with it uh they care they lecture us all
the time about the importance and the
sovereignty of other Count's borders but
they don't care at all about the
sovereignty of our own border and it's a
mess and so again I think this is a a
different value proposition between
Republicans and Democrats Republicans
want to secure the border the house has
moved forward hr2 uh that is serious
legislation and the Senate is playing
you know the Senate Democrats are
playing footsie with this all for the
you know stated goal of just releasing
the money for Ukraine so I think we
ought to be very cautious in these
negotiations because uh they're not
serious the Democrats are not serious
about securing the Border they believe
in open borders that's what they've got
and they're not going to change course
even if there's some you know tweak to
the law if you have an executive branch
not interested in executing the law
we're at where we're at and that's not
going to
change
real quick Senator would you be willing
to shut down the government to secure
the border for
real yeah look this is a serious issue
and I don't think that we should be
going along here with these continuing
resolutions which is what they're
talking about if we don't secure our own
border so I've been very clear about
this which by the way highlights why we
need to have individual appropriation
bills this Omnibus stuff the American
people are tired of it I've advocated
for this these debates should be
separate um you know Israel should be
separate from Ukraine this border stuff
we can isolate these issues and actually
deal with it and the American people
then can hold us to account as opposed
to this you know come up at the stroke
of midnight with something people
haven't read and say you you know you
either support this or you want to shut
down the government we have to have a
secure
border it's no way to run a country
Senator thank you very much for your
time hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get anywhere
else